son las 8 de la noche en viaja ciudad
del sur musulmán tailandés como de
costumbre la patrulla de vigilancia
inicia su ronda nocturna estos policías
le temen a los atentados de los grupos
separatistas que gangrenan la región
desde hace 20 años pero desde hace unos
meses también vigilan a las parejas de
jóvenes menores de edad que coquetean
entre sí
creo que lo que haces en oberá
si hubiéramos encontrado mujeres que no
fueran sus hermanas primas o tías
entonces nos habríamos dirigido al imán
al jefe del distrito y jefe del pueblo
para que viniera a buscarlos
la gran mayoría de los 15.000 habitantes
de jach'a son musulmanes al igual que el
85% de los habitantes en el sur de
tailandia hace poco las fuerzas de
seguridad y el alcalde de la ciudad
llegaron a un acuerdo con las
autoridades religiosas locales para
implementar el cumpa cat
inspirado en la sharia este decreto
municipal le permite a las fuerzas de
seguridad y también a los voluntarios
abordar a los adolescentes que vean
coqueteando no tienen el derecho de
conducirlos a la cárcel pero pueden
llevarlos ante el imán para una lección
de moral
la semana de la vida
si tengo miedo de que me detengan por
haber infringido el look um para cat eso
sería una deshonra para mi familia
un fenómeno nuevo en un país reconocido
por la tolerancia de sus costumbres
según algunos activistas este decreto
sería inconstitucional pero se aprovecha
de la doble legislación que reina en las
tres provincias musulmanas en el sur de
tailandia antiguo sultanato
independiente la sharia siempre estuvo
permitida para los asuntos familiares un
término vago que los partidarios de una
moral estricta aprovecharon para crear
esta brigada de las costumbres la ley
actual no le impide a los jóvenes
adolescentes sentarse juntos conversar
besarse entonces que debemos hacer esa
es la razón por la cual debemos resolver
este problema
en la mezquita de jach'a es el momento
de la oración sagrada del viernes en las
provincias del sur
el imán no solo tiene un poder religioso
a veces es llamado para solucionar
asuntos familiares una disputa por
herencia por matrimonio desde hace poco
tiene la tarea adicional de ceremonial a
las parejas jóvenes que no están casadas
detenidas por la policía
aunque sea el promotor moral de lúcuma
cat trata sin embargo de minimizar su
campo de aplicación el look back at no
es lo mismo que la sharia no obligamos a
los jóvenes adolescentes a casarse como
lo han dicho los medios no no hacemos
eso el look ump a cat es nuestra
herramienta de prevención para evitar
que nuestros jóvenes cometan abusos sólo
aplica para los musulmanes queremos
poder mantener por completo a nuestros
niños en el buen camino del islam mismo
discurso en la escuela coránica para
jóvenes enfrente de la mezquita entre
velos y plegarias las adolescentes
comparten el sentimiento general de los
habitantes de viajar esta política en
nuestra comunidad es muy buena
y eso es más seguro que la seguridad la
prioridad de la población civil en el
sur los movimientos separatistas armados
aún siguen operando desde hace 16 años
en las tres provincias musulmanas del
sur se encuentran en estado de
emergencia militar y en la noche en esos
enclaves de violencia
las patrullas buscan bandas terroristas
y traficantes de drogas
de hecho el cumpa cut se implementó para
ponerle fin a la delincuencia
implementamos las nuevas reglas raíz de
un incidente grave que ocurrió aquí hubo
un tiroteo entre unas bandas de jóvenes
una manera de retomar el control sobre
la juventud
segura
nos encontramos con anciana en la ciudad
vecina de pattani una del
independentismo esta militante por los
derechos humanos es una de las pocas en
atreverse a alzarse contra esta nueva
policía de las costumbres realmente no
creo que todo el mundo en el distrito de
jazz acepte el concepto de ocumo para
cat no deberían consultar solamente a
los hombres sino también a las mujeres y
a los jóvenes antes de imponer esta
regla
los jóvenes con los que hablamos no
habían sido consultados
sin embargo desconfían de esta
moralización de su vida cotidiana desde
que está el ucam para que no volvía ya
ja
hay bloqueos eso me parece una locura en
algunos pueblos más alejados cuando
pillan a esos jóvenes los obligan a
casarse esta joven pareja mixta
musulmana budista no acepta estas nuevas
restricciones en el coqueteo entre
jóvenes es algo normal cuando uno se
quiere
yo no estoy de acuerdo con eso es como
quitarnos nuestra libertad nosotros nos
queremos entonces si eso ocurre aquí
iremos juntos
[Música]
/ tradicionalismo y modernidad
obediencia y desconfianza el cumpa k
tenía ya logró erradicar la delincuencia
a costa de la libertad de los jóvenes
ese decreto podría ser extendido a otras
ciudades en el sur tailandés